well secretary general very good of you
to uh talk to us here on sky news
tonight now let's discuss these reports
of russian troops and some equipment
apparently being withdrawn from the
vicinity of ukraine and you'll be aware
of the foreign ministry spokesperson
maria zakharova tweeting that western
war propaganda has failed it was
humiliated and destroyed without a shot
being fired does nato see real evidence
of a de-escalation here
not so far uh we have not seen any uh
de-escalation any withdrawal of russian
troops and equipment uh but of course we
hope that will happen because we are
calling on russia to
to de-escalate and
and uh
to engage in in dialogue with russia
sorry with nato and nato allies to find
a political solution well if there is no
de-escalation are we still on track with
those intelligence warnings from the
last few days and hours from the united
states from the uk i'm sure from nato as
well that russia is in a position to
invade at any time and it could happen
in 24 hours time
so what we have seen over the last weeks
is a very significant russian military
buildup they have amassed
unprecedented number of combat ready
troops in and around ukraine
and also deployed a lot of high-end
capabilities missiles
artillery planes and many other
enablers support to those combat troops
so they can launch an attack on ukraine
with hardly any or no warning time
whatsoever this is of course a very
dangerous situation to be in and that's
the reason why we are sending a very
clear message to russia that if they
once again use uh
violence and military force against
ukraine
that will come with a high cost and we
have also increased our presence in
eastern part of the alliance and the uk
is leading in those efforts and i
welcome the efforts by the united
kingdom to both engage with russia but
also to increase the nato presence in
eastern part of the alliance so would
you say to those that read into these
reports of some troop withdrawals of a
de-escalation some hope that perhaps
violence may be avoided don't be fooled
by that this could be i think it's uh
called maskarovska by the russians
frenzy of different faints from
different directions to conceal the
intended final lethal punch this could
be actually a smoke screen
we have not seen any uh
withdrawal or the escalation on the
ground
but we will continue to monitor very
closely we will follow what they are
doing and we call on them to de-escalate
and it's not
too late to russia to
remove forces to start
[Music]
to engage in real efforts to find a
political uh solution and to stop the
operation uh the preparations for
aggressive actions so so we have this
dual track approach we need to send a
clear message that there will be costs
that that nato is increasing its
presence in eastern part alliance but at
the same time that we are ready to sit
down with russia and engage in
diplomatic efforts well it would be
appreciated secretary general if you
could give us as detailed a picture as
you can
of a possible political and diplomatic
solution with russia that satisfies its
objections to nato expansion now i know
you sent nato's proposals alongside the
us too to russia back in january and uh
they talk about arms control missiles
areas like that could there be some
common ground
absolutely
we have seen before that it's possible
to agree with russia on arms control and
we can do that again
for instance when it comes to missiles
when it comes to
different types of offensive weapons but
that has to be
reciprocal balanced and verifiable
but we are ready to engage in that we're
also ready to sit down with russia and
to for instance
address issues like transparency on
military activities to
prevent enemies understanding
miscalculations
and that is also helping to that will
also help to reduce attentions
but we are not willing uh not ready uh
uh to compromise on uh core principles
the right of every nation to choose its
own path including whether it wants to
belong to or not belong to an alliance
an alliance as as nato and then we
cannot compromise on this idea that we
don't have the right to protect those
allies that are in the eastern part of
the alliance we don't have first and
second class
nato members we have 30 nato allies and
we of course
must have the right to protect and
defend all of them so
could a possible solution be something
like this that um of course
the ukrainians right to join nato
remains there as a sovereign nation but
we take on board what olaf schultz said
yesterday when he was in kiev that
practically it's not on the agenda nato
membership president zadenski of ukraine
says membership
remains a dream and that nato then says
to the russians well of course we
deserve the right for the ukrainians to
join us but we will never put any
missiles on their soil
so first of all when it comes to arms
control we have made it clear again and
again that we are ready to engage in in
agreements talks about arms control uh
and we have done that before we
in 1987 we had what we call the inf
agreement uh
not limiting but actually removing
banning all intermediate range weapons
both uh dual both nuclear capable and
conventional capital uh intermediate
range missiles we have seen also
significant uh
limitations on the longer range missiles
so we have proven before that it is
possible uh to limit to reduce
uh to actually ban uh different
categories of missiles
and we can do that again as long as it's
balanced um
second
uh
ukraine is a server nation so it's for
them to decide whether they want to
apply for membership or not and then
it's for 30 allies to decide on the
issue whether ukraine is ready meet the
nato standards
and and that principle we cannot
compromise on then i think that any
successful
diplomatic effort to find a solution has
to have a minimum of confidentiality uh
so uh i i don't think it's wise if i go
to all into all the possible uh and
impossible options for
uh
common ground between russia and nato
allies
we had to meet and that's exactly why we
invited russia to meet in the nato
russia council and in other formats to
sit down and listen to their concerns
but also
share our concerns and then try to find
a common way forward well we appreciate
you going as far as you could there
secretary general and can i just ask you
as well when we're talking about attacks
on ukraine and indeed on other nato
members are we over concentrating on the
the hardware and the personnel i'm
talking of course as nato has warned
about in the past cyber attacks russia
is in a position to cause a great deal
of damage
so what we see now is that russia has
the capabilities in place to launch a
full-fledged invasion
of ukraine but also
of course there can be
other types of aggressive actions more
limited military incursion
subversion attempts to topple the
ukrainian
government or
a big very damaging cyber attacks we
need to be prepared for all of that and
we also need to be able to identify and
actually hold accountable and
responsible russia even if they do
something which is beloved or not a
full-fledged invasion and that's why we
share so much information in nato why we
need to to be vigilant and continue to
expose russia
on their what they are planning for and
and the different actions because we
need to be able to hold them accountable
if they do something which is not a
full-fledged generation but still a very
aggressive action against ukraine for
instance cyber attacks and lastly i must
just put you some of the russian
characterizations i know you're well
aware of them but interesting to get
your response first and foremost that
russia says it has a perfect right to
carry out military exercises wherever it
likes on its own territory and with its
allies and also uh it attests that nato
is not just a defensive organization it
does initiate actions such as in in
serbia and libya
so first
what we have seen is that
nato is a defensive alliance because we
have been there to defend and protect uh
uh uh
all nato allies for more than 70 years
then in for instance the balkans we
acted because we saw atrocities we saw
uh we saw uh violence against the
innocent civilians and nato helped to
end two brutal ethnic wars in the in the
balkans and we have stayed there since
then based on the u.n mandate we also
had the u.n mandate
in in
in libya
so so nato is and will remain a
defensive alliance then um i've
forgotten your law your first question
just the fact that russia says it can
carry out exercises on its own territory
wherever and whenever it likes
well the the answer to that is that of
course every nation has the right to
exercise their own troops on their own
territory uh that's absolutely
acceptable but this this is not a normal
exercise this is the biggest
concentration of combat
forces
in europe since the end of the cold war
uh and they are close to ukraine's
borders they're partners inside the
ukrainian territory in crimea and also
in donbass
and this is unprecedented and they have
all the neighbors in place to launch a
full-fledged invasion with hardly any
warning time at all
uh so this is a unprecedented military
buildup it is unjustified and
unexplained
combined with threatening rhetoric
because what they have said is that if
we don't
give in to the russian demands then
there will be what they call military
technical consequences so not only
military buildup but are also
threatening rhetoric combined with
the track record of russia russia has
invaded ukraine before
so military buildup threatening rhetoric
and a bad track record of course then we
have to take that very seriously and
that's exactly what nato is doing and uk
is very much part of that i'm thankful
for uk's contributions to our collective
defense and just as you've touched on
the irony of the russian position the
russian actions is that uh rather than
having less nato close to its borders
this is going to lead to to more nato
presence
yes that's exactly what we have seen
also before um nato didn't have any
combat troops in the eastern part of the
alliance uh before 2014. then after the
illegal annexation of crimea in 2014
we deployed for the first time in our
history
battlegroups to the baltic countries and
poland
united kingdom leads the battlegroup in
estonia
and
we have also invested more in defense we
have more exercises so we have more
presence in air on land and at sea uh as
a consequence of the aggressive actions
by russia in 2014 so if the purpose of
the russian aggressive actions is to get
less nato
close to the borders they get the exact
opposite they get more nato and that's
the case also now
we have increased our presence in the
eastern part alliance
as a direct response to the
very substantial russian military
buildup in iran ukraine
secretary general we appreciate your
time thank you very much indeed
thank you so much for having me